with Avengers infinity war right around
the corner and Black Panther also about
to be released in just a couple of weeks
it's getting very exciting to be able to
see all of our favorite characters on
screen again so soon so what exactly
will Avengers infinity war be all about
just as it leads to in the title it will
be a war for the Infinity stones so what
exactly are the Infinity stones as the
collector States and guardians of the
galaxy before the universe began there
were six similarities after the universe
came into existence beings known as
cosmic entities formed the singularities
into the six Infinity stones the
Infinity stones each represent a
different aspect of the universe space
mind reality power time and soul each
having different powers that only beings
of extraordinary strength can harness so
what are the powers of the Infinity
stones and where are they now
first the space stone the space stone is
the tesseract that was introduced to us
and Captain America the First Avenger
which eventually fell into the hands of
Loki who used it in the first Avengers
movie to open a portal on earth that
allowed the Chitauri to invade after the
Avengers stopped the invasion and closed
the portal Thor took the tesseract back
to Asgard where odd and locked it away
we see the tesseract again in Thor
Ragnarok when Loki is in Odin's trophy
room which may lead people to believe
that this is where it still is but
knowing Loki and how he is he definitely
took it as he walked by it especially
knowing that his home Asgard was about
to be destroyed we also have this
confirmed with the new Avengers infinity
war trailer that came out we see Loki
standing with the tesseract in his hand
in the middle of what looks like chaos
and destruction next is the mine stone
the mine stone was the stone that was
inside Loki's scepter that he used in
the first Avengers movie to control
people's minds it wasn't until the
second Avengers movie
age of Ultron that it was revealed to be
an infinity stone it currently sits in
visions forehead after he was created by
Tony Stark and Bruce Banner aka the Hulk
in an attempt to upload the AI jarvis
into a synthetic body Ultron I had
created as an upgrade for himself
powered by the mine stone as we saw in
Captain America Civil War
stone is still a part of vision then we
have the reality stone the reality stone
was introduced to us and Thor the dark
world as the ether the ether has the
power to control reality allowing its
will dirty ability to bend the laws of
reality and physics and also allowing
his will dirt to turn matter into dark
matter
Malekith tried to harness its power in
an attempt to destroy the nine realms
but of course the Mighty Thor stopped
him and seized the ether in the after
the credits scene of Thor the dark world
we see the ether being given to the
collector in nowhere which is where it
currently resides the power stone the
power stone made its appearance and
guardians of the galaxy as the orb the
power stone gives the Wilderland energy
and even enhanced powers that the
wielder may already have it is raw
energy we see its power explained and
demonstrated when the collector servant
Carina tries to harness the stone in an
attempt to kill the collector but
instead gets destroyed herself by its
power we see the power again when the
collector speaks of the ore being used
by the celestial s on the searcher to
destroy life on entire planets after
defeating Ronan the accuser the
guardians of the galaxy give it to the
Nova Corps at xander for safekeeping
which is where it currently remains the
time stone the time stone gives its
wielder the power to control time which
we see demonstrated in Doctor Strange
the time stone was and is kept in the
eye of agamotto
where it was kept by the Masters of the
mystic arts which is now used by dr.
strange himself we see its power at the
end of Doctor Strange where Doctor
Strange controls time by putting time in
a never-ending loop to defeat Dormammu
which he eventually does the time stone
is still kept with the Masters of the
mystic arts and Doctor Strange the last
stone is the sole stone and the soul
stone allows a user the ability to steal
control manipulate and alter living and
dead souls the soul stone is the last
one that hasn't been revealed to us yet
in the MCU which leads to several
proposed theories about where it is
located one of the theories is that
Heimdall has the soul stone seen as he
is a beam of incredible power and can
see every living soul in existence
another theory is that Adam warlock will
have the soul stone this is a very
popular theory that is going around
right now
we see Adams cocoon in the after the
credits scene in guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 and in the comics Adam is
imprisoned inside the cocoon with the
soul stone there's also the fact that
Adam actually kills Stannis in the
comics as well which gives good reason
to believe that he will be in Avengers
infinity war another theory that is
relatively popular is the soul stone is
in Wakanda and that it will be revealed
to us in black panther when it was
released shortly on February 16th these
are the soul stones what they are and
where they are in Avengers infinity war
we will see the mad Titan Thanos attempt
to collect all of the stones and put
them in his Infinity Gauntlet the
Infinity Gauntlet is one of if not the
most powerful weapon in the MCU universe
it is a tool that is used to harness all
the power of the stones giving the
wielder of the gauntlet complete control
of the universe and making them
unstoppable I'm so excited to see the
Avengers take on Thanos and infinity war
and curious to see which theory will pan
out in the movie what do you think will
happen in Avengers infinity war leave
your comments below and subscribe to my
channel to keep up to date with Avengers
infinity war and all things superhero
thank you so much for watching and have
a great day